Why do humans return to Pandora in Avatar:
The Way of Water?
Is it for more unobtanium?
James Cameron might just surprise you!
At its core, the "Avatar" franchise is an
outlandish science fiction fantasy.
With its bizarre bevy of colorful creatures
and fantastical vistas, the world of Pandora
undeniably embraces its strange concepts and
finds exciting ways to expand upon them continuously.
However, the franchise's way of presenting
these larger-than-life ideas alongside its
social commentary remains most intriguing,
even if it's far from the first sci-fi flick
to do this.
One of these attempts to connect the franchise's
wondrous settings to a real-world dilemma
is with the special compound unobtanium.
In the first "Avatar," we learn that Unobtanium
acts as a powerful superconductor, which those
on Earth seek to use as a power source, given
the energy crisis they are experiencing.
However, the Na'Vi people forbid the mining
of it, as they view the Tree of Souls, where
it is located as a sacred place.
The environmental metaphor may be pretty on
the nose, but it is nevertheless an integral
part of the story "Avatar" tries to tell about
our inner connection with nature and how far
we are willing to fight for it.
"I am a warrior like you, i'm supposed to
fight"
So it's all the more surprising that the film's
sequel, "Avatar: The Way of Water," never
mentions Unobtanium.
That's right, the very element that caused
the central conflict in Pandora's history
is not given a single mention in "The Way
of Water."
So what does the absence of this crucial substance
mean for the greater "Avatar" story moving forward?
The term Unobtanium is not present in "Avatar:
The Way of Water," but that doesn't mean the
idea behind the substance is lost.
The film sees Colonel Miles Quaritch return
in an Avatar body to take down Jake Sully
and his family.
When Sully decides to move his family beyond
the outskirts of their forest home, they join
the Metkayina tribe of the ocean, who teaches
the family their ways.
Amongst the most crucial aspects of the Metakiyna
way of life comes their connection to the
whale-like creatures, the Tulkuns.
The people hold the intelligent creatures
in extremely high regard, seeing them as siblings
and forming lifelong connections with the
animals from birth.
In an attempt by Quaritch and his band of
goons to lure Sully from hiding, they team
up with a ship of Tulkun hunters who help
kill the animals to cause distress to the
Metakiyna clan.
However, after killing the animals, the hunters
drill into their heads and take out a gloppy
liquid that is incredibly valuable, with even
a small canister worth millions.
In this way, the Tulkuns stand in as a similar
piece of symbolism that the Unobtanium did
in the first film as a precious natural resource
that humanity seeks to exploit.
It serves the message here, but even more
significantly, it paints a picture of what
we can expect in the franchise's future.
The seemingly forgotten Unobtanium might confuse
viewers coming into "Avatar: The Way of Water."
As an essential plot point of the first film,
it seems natural that this long-awaited sequel
finds new ways to expand and build upon what
we already know about the valuable substance.
But just as "The Way of Water" explores new
and exciting lands in Pandora instead of staying
in the same place as its predecessor, the
film chooses to evolve in its thematic nature
as well.
"This family is our fortress"
Keep in mind that "The Way of Water" takes
place more than a decade after the first film's
events.
In that time, the energy crisis on Earth has
likely taken over or, if not, is very close
to doing so.
Is Unobtanium still strong enough to solve
the issue?
Even if it proves powerful, it's more than
likely that Colonel Quaritch and his gang
will find similarly valuable resources throughout
Pandora and find some way to exploit them
for their own use.
The war against humanity is about more than
protecting the Na'vi people and the life on
Pandora, but the heart and soul of the planet
itself that keeps everything in check.
"The Way of Water" tells us that there is
no one little piece that matters as much as
it is the entirety of the world that deserves
saving.